[ rap music ]
>>Narrator: This Fremont High School
student video shows how some students
spend their spare time and
money in the turbulent world
of car side shows.
>>Student: I'm probably
going to add some stuff.
>>Narrator: But another group
of Fremont students spends their
after school hours
doing community service
and running small business ventures.
And this year, their diligence
carried them into the finals
of a competition for the best
high school business program
in the country.
>>Student: It creates a truancy
problem on our school campus,
because many students venture
off campus to buy candy and soda.
>>Student: Is a dollar-twenty-five
good?
>>Narrator: Like most great ventures,
this one began with a simple idea.
To make money selling good food
from an on-campus lunch cart.
>>Student: Come buy our ribs, chicken
sandwich, they're really good!
>>Narrator: In one semester,
the student-run business
sold about 6,000 meals.
Generating 20,000 dollars in sales,
and reducing post-lunch truancy,
which had been running at
a staggering 72 percent.
>>Student: The truancies were
high last year, and the absences.
We decided that if we can keep as
many students in school as possible,
they would decrease, plus
we'd get business also.
>>Narrator: These young entrepreneurs
are members of the "Students
In Free Enterprise," or SIFE
team, an after-school offshoot
of Fremont's Business Academy.
In addition to running
the lunch cart,
they opened several other
businesses, based on an assessment
of the needs of the community.
>>Student: So you currently
don't have your W2?
>>Student: Hm-mm.
>>Narrator: Fifteen students
passed a rigorous federal exam,
qualifying them to act as licensed
tax advisors to their peers
and other community members.
>>Student: At line 36 and 37?
>>Narrator: The SIFE team also
started a tutoring program,
and a business card design firm.
>>Student: Much bigger, ten?
Twelve?
>>Student: Twelve.
>>Narrator: They also responded
to Fremont's request for proposals
for new small learning communities,
and ended up designing an
entirely new curriculum.
>>Student: Expeditionary
learning, authentic assessment,
cycle of inquiry, multiple
intelligence,
and culturally relevant pedagogy.
>>Nidya: Yes, Youth Empowerment
School, it's totally a new idea.
It's based on the Five
Theories of Instruction.
And it's completely
project-based, and for students
to take their education
into their own hands.
And our experience with SIFE made us
want to go to school, work real hard,
do more project-based
learning, community service.
And so we said, "Why can't
everybody learn this way?"
>>Narrator: In addition
to running the businesses,
and working on their
new school design,
the SIFE team entered a
statewide competition,
where they would make a multi-media
presentation of their work
to a panel of industry judges.
>>Nidya: My high school, Nidya.
>>D'Andre: Wassup?
My name is D'Andre Williams.
>>Narrator: The Fremont team
had been a surprise winner
in last year's competition.
But as tryouts began for
this year's presenters,
repeating seemed a distant dream.
>>Veronica: Well, my name's Veronica
Garcia, and I'm auditioning to see
if I can present at SIFE.
Here I go.
Our mission is to create a
safe place for our community.
>>Student: Participate in a
[inaudible] free of charge.
>>Student: Although we value
our entrepreneurialship,
we also value the community.
>>Veronica: We also--
although we value entrepreneur,
we also value our community.
[laughs] Yeah.
>>Teacher: But that blurb
had an error of parallelism,
so I can find it for you.
>>Student: Parallelism?
>>Teacher: Yeah, there's faulty
parallelism somewhere here.
"Establishing, analyze and
conduct," it has to be "Establishing,
analyzing and conducting," right?
>>Student: We're always on the go.
>>Veronica: Okay, see?
That's where it comes in.
>>Student: So that's where I'm
going-- we are always on the go.
>>Veronica: See?
That's where it comes in.
On the go, yeah.
>>Student: So I should move this way.
>>Veronica: Yeah, unless you're--
if you want to do that, you know?
[laughs] Don't do it
too long, though.
>>Student: Oh, okay.
We're always on the go.
>>Group: Aaaaah.
>>Teacher: Think about
sending your note.
We're going to pick a spot.
It's right here.
>>Jamie: There is the
whole other side
of what kids learn going
through high school.
>>Jamie: Well, a lot of people
learn how to be evasive,
how to be invisible, how to like
not look like you know the answer.
You have to unlearn that
to become a performer.
>>Group: Veronica!
>>Student: Our needs
assessment shows that last year
over nine million dollars
went unclaimed in Oakland.
>>Yvonne: This means that out
of a hundred tenth graders
only three graduate.
>>Amy: Yvonne, when
she first rehearsed,
had some issues with language.
She's a second language learner.
>>Yvonne: That the Business Academy
had a shocking graduation rate
of only 30 percent.
This means...
>>Amy: I taught her
English last year,
and never once did she
contribute to class.
When she was audible,
she was very quiet
and soft-spoken, and
she was very shy.
So when she stepped up to
present, we were delighted
that this student was
choosing to grow so much.
>>Yvonne: This chart shows
senior graduation rates from...
>>Jamie: Wait, wait, wait.
Which chart?
That chart?
>>Yvonne: Yeah.
>>Jamie: Vanna White!
That beautiful chart that all
of your students made with you!
It's amazing!
Look at where our tax money's going!
Right there, okay?
>>Kevin: It's amazing to see
our six presenters get up.
Some of them were pretty darn shy.
And to see them really blossom, and
to get up and they're speaking out,
and they're confident and they
have amazing presentation skills.
Now they're really building on them.
So they're doing a great job.
The students have taken
ownership of it.
So they wrote the speeches, and
they're editing and constructing
and changing their speeches.
They're making and
building the PowerPoint,
so everything they do,
they're going to retain.
These are real skills that
will stay with the students.
>>Student: We even did the
taxes of one of our presenters.
>>Jamie: Right.
>>D'Andre: I made thirteen bucks!
>>Jamie: Nice.
Okay. Let's go back.
>>Student: We even did the
taxes of one of our presenters.
>>D'Andre: I made thirteen bucks!
>>Student: And because we live
in such a diverse community,
we even offer our services
in Espanola.
>>Veronica: Our participation
in SIFE last year encouraged us
to begin our own small school.
As we began the long
work [inaudible],
we took part in all areas
of producing this school,
from writing a 35-page RFP, to
going to local middle schools,
where we made classroom
presentations.
>>Nidya: We practiced, and
we rehearsed questions.
One, because we're so out of it that
we weren't giving it our best at all,
because we're just so tired.
>>Nidya: Aloha!
My name is Nidya Baez.
>>Nidya: But we woke up
at 4:45 in the morning.
>>Woman: Wow.
>>Veronica: Here are the preliminary
results of our qualitative data.
>>Veronica: It's challenging for us
because, you know, we are low-income,
you know, people in Oakland.
But we needed to look presentable.
We didn't want to mismatch or
look like clothed in a bit of...
>>Nidya: You left this
one too short now.
>>D'Andre: I didn't really
have no money to get no suit,
so Ms. Carpenter she took me to go
get a vest and slacks and a shirt,
so I could wear it
for the presentation.
>>Nidya: One of the judges called us
too preppy, and we were surprised,
because it's like we just know
how to dress for the occasion.
We needed to be dressed
professionally for that.
>>Student: Are you nervous?
Are you nervous?
Yeah.
>>Student: Do the hand motion.
>>Yvonne: [speaks Spanish] My
name is Yvonne [inaudible].
>>Tiana: [speaks Spanish] My name is Tiana Seamore.
>>Nidya: It's a tough world,
especially in the business world.
It's predominated by white males.
And it's tough to be a Latina,
and it's tough to be a woman,
and it's tough to be from Oakland,
and it's really challenging.
>>Veronica: And I am Veronica
Garcia, the Executive Director
of Fremont SIFE, and
we are here today
to show you how we are
sparking hope in our world.
>>Veronica: Me, personally,
I wanted to succeed.
I want to show everybody
I can do better
than what they think I could do.
And it's like with SIFE we have
the opportunity to show them,
you know, we're not stupid.
We have a lot of drive in us.
You know, we could do
anything we put our minds to.
>>Teacher: And the first
runner-up, second place goes
to Golden West High School.
>>Students: [cheering]
>>D'Andre: I was happy.
'Cause I never been a part
of anything like this really.
So after we won, I was excited.
>>Narrator: The next
day Williams learned
that his cousin had been fatally
wounded in a drive-by shooting.
>>D'Andre: Oakland's public
image is not exactly wrong.
The City's problems have been
way over-covered by the media.
Every time we turn around...
>>Narrator: But five weeks later,
he traveled with his team to compete
for the SIFE National
Championship in Kansas City.
>>D'Andre: Yet, amidst this darkness
that surrounds us the
fire of hope is growing.
>>Amy: I think the presentation part
of it really helps build their
confidence, and makes them so proud
of themselves that they don't
let these barriers that were
in the way before get
in their way now.
That keeps them safe when they go out
into the street, because they know
that in their heart that they don't
have to appear to be someone else
in order to have status
in their community.
I don't think that's enough
to protect them from something
like a stray bullet, which is
something that happens a lot
in Oakland, but it's enough
to help them make good choices
that could save their lives.
>>Student: This way students
can represent their schools
and class instead of
representing gangs.
>>Teacher: Any comments?
>>Yvonne: I feel great and confident.
To me, we're the winners.
And whatever happens.
And I will always have
the confidence.
>>Judge: The Champion team
from the USA is the team
from the Fremont Business
Academy in Oakland, California.
>>Students: [cheering] [applause]
>>Narrator: After graduating
Veronica Garcia
and Nidya Baez began the fall
semester at the University
of California at Berkeley.
And the Youth Empowerment School the
SIFE team created welcomed its first
freshman class in September of 2003.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.